wolves wizards vampires and werewolves
just a few of the mythical beings you'll
find in harry potter and twilight
these fantasy stories are chock-full of
exciting characters and moments
of which we have noticed some
similarities now that's not to say that
these two series are the same
but there are definitely some aspects
that look familiar
across both franchises and not just the
fact that robert pattinson plays both
sides
so to all the twilighters and
potterheads join together as we dive in
to see what we can find in these worlds
of wizards and vampires
you can't have a vampire story without
blood
in twilight it's what gives the vampire
strength both mentally and physically
this actually is also an occurrence in
harry potter in the sorcerer's stone
a weakened voldemort drinks unicorn
blood to keep himself alive
because if anyone was going to be a
blood sucking unicorn killer
it was of course going to be voldemort
now a fight between voldemort and the
colons is something i would like to see
we will not fight today
they say the future is unpredictable but
that's not the case for certain harry
potter and twilight characters
alice from twilight can get visions of
the future which is an extremely useful
power
i'm sure you all remember the now
infamous fight scene that never was
where alice showed arrow his grim future
harry potter has professor trelawny
who was able to predict the future she's
the one who predicted
the prophecy about voldemort and harry
both these characters are very important
in influencing the story have i said
something
shape-shifting is an ability we see
characters utilize
in both worlds in twilight members of
the yule packs
such as jacob black can shapeshift into
wolves at will
they take this form for protection and
to fight their enemies
in harry potter there are multiple
different kinds of shapeshifters
anime guys shapeshifters can transform
into an animal
at will for example sirius black can
transform into a dog professor
mcgonagall a cat
and peter pettigrew a rat there are also
werewolves such as professor lupin but
his transformation is out of his control
and occurs only
during a full moon
[Music]
turns out wizards and vampires are both
very athletic beings who love sports
for the wizarding world it's the unique
game of quidditch which sees players
flying around
on broomsticks for vampires it's
baseball but it's not your average game
as vampires are so strong that they can
only play during thunderstorms that will
mask the sound of them hitting the ball
these are both very intense sports that
seem very fun to play
now i want a nice clean game in worlds
filled with magical creatures and beings
it's kind of funny that in both series
there is a high fascination with humans
and their involvement in the mythical
world in harry potter muggle-born
wizards and witches
or mudbloods as some people call them
are an uncommon type of wizard and there
is debate as to whether they are
deserving of magic
in twilight there is the extremely rare
hybrid a child born from a human and a
vampire
examples include hermione who is a
muggleborn and renes may
the daughter of edward and bella who is
a hybrid
half mortal half
immortal a wise old man with extensive
knowledge is pivotal for any fantasy
series
and these two are no exception
dumbledore and billy black give the
characters
and the audience all the exposition they
need
billy black is the wise spiritual leader
that tells bella all about the wolf
tribe's past
dumbledore gives harry the information
he needs by letting him directly view
his memories
in both cases our heroes acquire vital
information through these wise old men
what happened
down in the dungeons between you and
professor qiddle
is a complete secret regular humans
don't get to have
any of the fun in these franchises as
people are kept in the dark about the
whimsical worlds around them
the wizarding world of harry potter has
rules and laws in place to keep their
secret from getting out with the
ministry of magic holding trials for any
wizard or witch that breaks these laws
this is similar to the volturi of
twilight who are the governing vampire
force meant to maintain balance and
secrecy from the human world
maybe one day humans will be allowed to
experience these worlds
[Music]
for being the heroes of the story harry
and bella sure do cause a lot of trouble
we've seen harry time and time again
break the rules create chaos and ignore
authority
whether it's opening the chamber of
secrets or using magic outside of school
bella is breaking the rules just by
being with a vampire who aren't allowed
to reveal their true selves to humans
of course both these characters only
have good intentions
and do what they do in the name of good
i solemnly swear that i'm up to no good
dumbledore's army and the cullens
working with the wolves are groups that
were both put together
in the name of protecting good against
evil they both train an
army to best prepare them for battle
against a big threat focusing on
specific skills and strategies that will
help them the most
we see these two groups in action
putting their skills to the test
as they are both successful in defeating
their enemies a job well done
all around well done
voldemort and his loyal death eaters
remind us a lot of arrow and the volturi
they are the antagonistic groups who
have it out for our heroes
relentlessly hunting them down we see
voldemort and arrow perish during the
big final showdown
even if arrow's demise was just a vision
of the future
also both these groups love their robes
what do we do with you now will there
ever be
a more highly debated love triangle than
edward jacob and bella
burger king even had a campaign centered
around this feud
well harry potter fans may have an
argument that the love triangles in
their series
are even more compelling in the half
blood prince we see a love struggle
between ron
lavender and hermione ron and hermione
end up together in the end
but some fans still insist that it's
hermione and harry that are the ones who
should have ended up together
perhaps these debates will truly never
end
i won't be going alone because believe
it or not someone's asked me
academic settings serve as a background
for a lot of these movies
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry is where harry meets ron and
hermione
kicking off their journey together and
although forks high school in twilight
isn't as magical
it is where bella meets edward kicking
off their journey together as well
of course no school setting would be
complete without a school dance
like the ones we see in both these
series i want you
always bella and harry are such a
big part of their franchises that not
even death can keep them down
they both bite the bullet towards the
end of their stories only to come back
and continue to fight
as the antagonists know it's extremely
hard to get rid of these two
harry potter is dead
causing tons of trouble also puts our
protagonists in a lot of danger
they always have a target on their back
and find themselves in situations that
are more than they can handle
luckily for them they have friends that
are willing to fight for them and
sacrifice themselves if they must
harry sees multiple people sacrifice
themselves for him
including dumbledore and snape bella on
the other hand
has people who once hated each other
coming together just to protect her
in the future vision alice has we see
multiple friends of bella parish
get yourself some friends like harry and
bella have
i have never met anyone more prone to
life-threatening idiocy
after defeating the big baddie and
bringing peace to their people
harry and bella's journeys come to a
very similar end
with both of them being married with
children they deserve these endings
after everything they have been through
and as far as we're concerned they live
happily ever after
now it's their children's turn to have
an adventure who knows
maybe we'll get those stories one day we
love these two series
and it's fun to find similarities after
all these years
as we continue to re-watch these movies
re-read the books and debate which one
is better
we're sure that more connections will be
spotted did you find any similarities
between
the wizarding world and the world of
vampires let us know